The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LARA BALADI: That
demonstration I had been to
was for peace in Lebanon
during the war in 2006.
And so it wasn't-- there was no
reason for so much police to be
there.
We were there to ask
for peace in the region.
So it wasn't about
revolution or toppling
the president or whatever.
So I was really
shocked that there
was this really
ridiculous kind of fear
from the Amn ad-Dawla,
the State Security.
And of course, what
happens is that when
somebody makes a little
gesture, and there's
like a panic movement.
And of course, the police takes
advantage of it and panics,
because they're 17 years
old or so, the policemen.
They're terrified.
And everybody's terrified.
Except they're armed.
And they start beating people
up and arresting people.
So from there, I thought
on the 25th of June,
I thought, I'm not going down.
I know what's going
to end up happening.
I'm going to get beaten up.
And then I realized I'm
like everybody else.
I'm afraid.
And the whole point
of the revolution
was to break that fear.
It was really that suddenly
nobody was afraid anymore,
and that we actually
really went.
And the fact that we were
all together in the street
was, like, OK, we're not
afraid, because also we're
all together.
And it was really extraordinary.
But I also saw that I wasn't
a photographer anymore.
I had, like, 25 years ago began
my career as a photographer
and kind of got a
little bit out of it
from watching digital
cameras and everybody
becoming a photographer was
also part of my-- sort of how
I evolved as an artist.
And so I moved into using
images, but not so much being
so focused on making images.
So for me, my role
in the revolution
was to really be
there as an Egyptian,
and to be there as a person
who loves that country,
and who wants to
really see something
through in that movement.
So I really put myself, as
an artist, actually outside
of everything, and for quite
a long time, just watched.
I participated.
I was there.
I met people.
I helped people.
I was in the Square
all the time.
But I did not take
lead in a way.
I did not produce art.
I didn't want to do anything.
I just thought this is too much.
I need to process
what's going on.
So it's much later
in the process
that I started to
kind of take action
in a way, or a different
action than being
a citizen demonstrating.
And this is when
these other Tahrir
Cinema and sort of very
time-based experiences
sort of happened.
But that we'll talk
about a bit later.
But my role, really-- I saw
my role as someone who could,
from my experience and the
community that I know, someone
who could really connect
people to each other,
and also watch a lot of
younger people than me,
and see that I could
really-- I had the experience
that they didn't have.
But they had, maybe,
the tools and the ways
to operate that I also-- my
generation-- didn't have.
My generation was much
more individualistic,
and also a little
bit like a satellite.
We worked as, like-- we
were apolitical, in a way.
We were sort of--
I think we were--
a lot of us were a
little bit outside
of the political sphere,
because that wasn't the way
to operate at the time.
So
To watch suddenly this
new generation come in
and be very, very strong about
their political views and using
social media and so
on was, like, OK,
what can I give that
they don't have?
And so it was really great.
Because I met a lot of people
and I worked in that way
with a lot of people.
So it was a very organic
time, in that sense.
And it led to a lot of
things which we'll talk about
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We have
a lot to talk about.
In the classroom last
week, we were asking
ourselves, what is an activist?
How much someone should
be involved in a cause
to qualify as an activist?
And we were comparing anonymous
members with Aaron Swartz.
And we were concluding that
Aaron Swartz was much more
dedicated to the
cause than people
who just do sit-in, online
sit-in from time to time.
I guess my question
would be in this case,
are all protesters activists
in the context of a revolution?
And do you consider
yourself as an activist?
And when does the artist
become an activist?
LARA BALADI: So no,
not every protester
is an activist-- for sure not.
I think every
protester is a citizen.
Every protester that
comes to a demonstration
doesn't necessarily
know why they're
coming to a demonstration.
But this is a huge discussion.
But in the case of
Tahrir, a lot of people--
there was something kind of
almost funny, when you look
at it in retrospect, is that--
I don't know if you remember,
if you know-- but on the 25th of
Jan, the first group of people
go and demonstrate.
On the 26th and 27th,
they-- the main activists
of that first
demonstration-- start
to kind of confuse the police
and exhaust the police, which
was a technique.
On the 28th of Jan, everybody
is called to come to the square.
It's a Friday.
In Egypt, Friday is the
equivalent of a Sunday.
On the 27th at night, before
this Friday where everybody's
on holiday-- nobody's
going to go to work,
so it's much more scary
for the government,
because they know
more people are
free to go demonstrating--
the tension was growing
throughout the country,
not just in Cairo.
And at 7:00 PM, there was rumors
that the government would stop
our telephones and internet.
At 9:00 PM, we couldn't talk
to each other on the phone.
We can only text.
At 11:00 PM, we couldn't text.
At 6:00 AM, we couldn't email
anybody or open internet.
So it's kind of stupid.
Because what do you do when you
don't have internet, telephone,
and you don't have
a landline anymore?
What's your natural instinct?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LARA BALADI: You go out,
try to go to [INAUDIBLE].
So it's in a funny
way, almost, I'd
say it's almost the government
helped initiate this
by shutting us down.
And so of course,
we're all going
to go look for each other.
So everybody goes
down to the street
in their area and talks to each
other, says, what's going on?
Oh, let's go to Tahrir.
Because of course, we
already know that there
are demonstrations going on.
So most of the
people are already
informed that there are
demonstrations and marches that
will start after
the Friday prayer
at 1:00 from a lot of the main
mosques around the cities.
But most of the people who
are not part of these marches
necessarily will sort
of naturally join.
And so this is what happened.
So people found out
about the reasons
why this is happening,
how this is shaping itself
as it was happening.
There was no real--
it's not like everybody
knew why they were going down.
So people found themselves
activists, maybe after five
days, 10 days, maybe overnight.
So a good example--
and he's here
Harvard if you have
a chance to go,
maybe meet him or find out about
him-- but there's somebody,
like a good example is
Bassem Youssef who's
a comic now that's compared
to Jon Stewart in the US.
But he was a heart surgeon.
He was a doctor.
He was studying.
I think he was still,
like, finishing
his studies or something, or
a very early practitioner.
He filmed himself talking about
what was happening, posted
the video on YouTube, three
months later had already five
million people watching him.
And then a month
later, a TV that
came out of the revolution--
so a free channel-- asked
him to do a show.
And he became a
really famous figure
over the period of two
years that followed.
So this is an example of
someone who's a citizen,
but then becomes an
activist, but then becomes--
finds a new voice for himself.
PROFESSOR: So it's a
fluid category, kind of.
LARA BALADI: So I mean,
everybody changed our life.
Like, I mean, everybody--
maybe a lot of people.
But I would say that
we all lost our friends
and made new friends.
Because suddenly when you
can't talk about politics,
you realize that you don't get
along with anyone around you.
And it's like, oops,
I don't think so.
This is such a huge,
impactful moment in history.
You cannot make a compromise.
There's no time for it.
There's no energy for it.
And it's going so fast,
and it's so intense.
You have to go to
what you believe for.
And so you make choices.
And these choices--
you watch people
sort of drop out of your life.
Suddenly, you're
completely negotiating
a completely differ-- so these
aren't fixed-- what you are
and how you [INAUDIBLE] that.
And to talk about how
an artist becomes,
what an artist does
in a revolution,
I mean, this example behind me
is a piece that I did in 2007.
And the revolution
started in 2011.
To give you a
configuration of Cairo,
you have those
famous lions that you
see the picture are the
entrance of a famous bridge,
called the [INAUDIBLE]
Bridge, [INAUDIBLE]
means bridge, so
the Nile Bridge.
And in front of those
lions, actually, is Tahrir.
So it's a landmark a little bit
like the Pyramids or the Eiffel
Tower.
It's a famous area in Cairo,
and people would naturally
go visit it.
And so in 2007, I
made this piece,
which is called
Justice for the Mother.
Egypt in Arabic is
called the Mother
of the World, Um al-Dunya.
And so this work was really a
work about-- it was actually
a portrait of my
father and a portrait
of the law of the
jungle-- the strongest
is always the one
that wins a fight.
But while I'm doing
this work and sort
of studying this
kind of psychology
of how human beings fight
each other, and who wins
and who loses,
using these images
that I've collected
in my work, I
attended this demonstration
I told you about,
where this huge cordon of
police was circling us.
And I was really shocked
by it, because nobody
in that demonstration
had the same purpose.
There was five or six
people who were actually
there for Lebanon.
But really, people were
there because either they
were passing by, or
they were activists,
or they were asking for the
bread to be less expensive.
I mean, everybody had a kind
of different cause and purpose.
And so this sort of
like weird incoherence
of that demonstration
really stuck with me.
And so this was a parody.
So this is a detail
of the piece where
it's a parody of people
demonstrating and asking
for something.
But everybody seems to
be, like, on their own.
So you can see John
Travolta, which
is not your generation,
but a little bit mine.
Condoleezza Rice during
the war in Lebanon,
so with bombs and missiles
that say, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, and all
kinds of character
that seem to be revolting.
And so interestingly,
when Tahrir started,
suddenly I look
at my work, and I
think, what am I
supposed to do now
that there's this
huge revolution
or uprising happening?
Am I supposed to work?
And I'm watching all these
kids and all these people
produ-- even citizens,
not just artists,
but citizens producing
videos, and uploading footage,
and making jokes, and doing
this crazy, amazing stuff.
And I don't work like this.
I work-- I take time to work.
And I worked under dictatorship.
So in a way, my work was
shaped by the stagnant regime
under which I was
working, and which
I was trying to also sort
of mirror by making work
that kind of demands
attention and in a sense
are heavy sometimes,
but that mirrored
that kind of rigidity of the
regime I was working under.
And looking back at this
work as one of the works
was really funny,
because I was, like, wow,
I depicted a kind of
problematic paradise
behind those lines,
which is-- it's
actually a portrait of Tahrir.
And that's how it
felt. That's how
the being 18 days
in the square really
felt like there was a
possible world that we
had to experience, and
we were experiencing
in very small moments.
But those moments where
this is a possibility,
this is a seed of
something that could
happen-- maybe in 2,000
years, maybe 200 years, maybe
in 10 years.
We don't know, maybe tomorrow.
I have no idea.
But it's possible.
And it's that sort
of sense that really
was really interesting for me.
And it took me a long
time to kind of think, OK,
how do I work now?
So this is also
another question.
Because then I start
collecting footage
and working with archive,
and collecting pictures.
But I wanted to show this
as a kind of relationship
to how the world
changed overnight.
And so there was a moment
of reflection and kind
of absorbing what was
happening before doing things.
PROFESSOR: This was made
before the revolution.
LARA BALADI: Yes, 2007,
four years before.
PROFESSOR: I think
it kind of shows
that your work was
already political
before the revolution, even
though you didn't really
notice.
There was something
political in--
LARA BALADI: No, I did notice.
I did notice.
But it was just a different
language I was using.
I mean, this work--
this is Cairo.
I want to show you.
These are informal
areas in Cairo,
which are basically illegal
constructions and slums.
And this was a tower that
I built in the Opera House
in the center of Cairo,
which is a military base,
and which is where
the Biennial of art
takes place-- used
to take place.
And so this work was
directly a kind of statement
to the government to say OK,
the subject of your Biennial
is the others.
So what are you doing
with the others?
Who are the others in
relationship to the government?
They're all the people
they're not addressing.
They're not
addressing the issues
that these people have
and face every day.
And so I built an informal
tower, a slum tower,
in the middle of the garden
of this military base.
I made my own brick.
You can see the donkey here.
And it says "hope" on it.
And here you can see the tower
at night with the Opera House
just behind.
And of course, this
was very controversial.
Because it was like, wow,
like putting people--
you don't go there.
So I'm going to
bring there to you.
And this was really like a year
before the revolution, a year
and a half before
the revolution.
So this work was really, really
loaded and very much discussed
later as a kind of
movement in the art world,
as how artists were putting
their-- saying, you know,
hello, alert, alert, beep, beep.
There's something happening
here that you need to look at.
So this was the
kind of landscape
we were in when the
revolution started
in terms of the art scene.
PROFESSOR: Yes, Ali.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] were
you inspired by Bosch?
LARA BALADI: That's what
everybody always tells me.
AUDIENCE: It looks so similar.
LARA BALADI: Thank
you very much.
It's always a very
beautiful compliment.
I actually love painting.
I'm not a painter.
And I wish I could be.
But I'm sure I will
be at some point.
I've made other
people paint for me.
Because in Egypt, we
have this tradition
of making painted
billboards for the cinema.
I mean, in the good old days,
they still existed like this.
But yes, a lot of
people compare my work
to Bosch because
of the kind of--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LARA BALADI: The delight,
the Paradise depiction.
But actually, when
you get closer to it,
it shows all the
disruptions that
are happening in this
depiction of Paradise
and how, in fact,
it's closer to Hell.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I saw the
similarity to the free expanse,
but also the two lions
separated into a very
three-paneled piece.
It also just seemed
very similar,
and I really like
that [INAUDIBLE].
LARA BALADI: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: OK, so now we'll
enter in the discussion
we're supposed to
have today related
to the assigned readings.
And what I did,
actually, is that I
used the assigned readings
to build my questions.
And I'm going to use these
questions as a pretext
to kind of push in a
little bit of theory,
so it looks more like a course
than just a casual discussion.
And then after, we'll
try to connect this
to your own
experience as someone
experimented the revolution.
So the first thing I
would like to talk about
is the rise of digital
rebellions, citizen journalism
and cyber left, which did
not start with the Arab
Spring and the Occupy
Movement, but started
12 years before with the
creation of Indymedia, which
is a global, federated network
of independent media centers,
radio stations, newspapers,
video collectives and websites.
And Indymedia was
already only funded
as an alternative and
a direct challenge
to corporate media
like CBS and CNN.
Most [INAUDIBLE] report on
the counter demonstration
and the police brutality
that took place
during the 1999 World Trade
Organization meetings.
And during its first
week, the website
received 1.5 million hits,
outpacing CNN website
for the same period.
It was quite something.
It was really big.
And as the platform
developed, it
became more than an alternative
media outlet, but also
a think tank and activist
laboratory and mobilizing tool
for the anti-globalization
movement.
So for those who don't remember,
the anti-globalization movement
was against free
trade agreements
that would be at the
disadvantage of the poorest.
And so this platform
was allowing people
different movement,
different struggle,
to kind of merge together
on the same platform--
movements as diverse as
the Zapatista-Mayan peasant
army from the poorest
region of Mexico,
the South central
farmer movement in LA,
a movement against
Wal-Mart in Philadelphia,
and movement
against war in Iraq.
So it was very diverse,
but it was all converging
on this platform here.
And at that time,
the activists were
using chatrooms, the listservs,
wiki pages where people could
upload their stories, their
report, their pictures,
their videos.
And so Indymedia was really
one of the first websites
where 100s of people were
uploading content, generating
content.
And in this book,
Digital Rebellion,
Todd Wolfson claimed that
Indymedia, with its slogan,
"Don't Hate the Media, Be the
Media," was kind of a precursor
or catalyst for
social media, but also
the grassroots journalism--
citizen journalism.
Lara, in your article,
"When Seeing is Belonging"
that is very good, and
I recommend everybody
to read it-- it's online-- you
argue that September 11 also
contributed to the rise
of citizen journalism.
You want to tell us a
little more about this idea?
LARA BALADI: Yes.
I mean, I wrote this article
because of my relationship
to photography, and how this
is how I began my career.
And I found it was quite
shocking to watch everybody--
can I go back to some
of these images--
to watch everybody take
photos in the square.
Like this is quite
an interesting image.
So watching this
kind of scene, and I
was myself holding a camera
that was actually broken.
So it was making scratch--
it had scratch like that.
I was, like, hmm,
look at everybody's
really documenting this.
And I look back at my life, and
thinking, OK, what do I do now?
Because I felt a bit frozen.
As I described, the way
I work is I need time.
And in a moment where
you're in the middle of a--
when the dam breaks, the river
goes really, really fast.
So you better be your
head out of the water
and go with the flow.
Which, in a stagnant
regime, it's
more like being in a lake
that is very stagnant.
And you have to keep going
down, and kind of trying
move [INAUDIBLE] so
that something happens.
So it's a very
different situation.
So that sense made me look
back, and maybe look back
at photography, and
the use of media,
and the use of image making,
the history of image making.
And I remember
starting photography
when I was coming out of school
and the first Gulf War started.
And that was a moment in
media where the war in Iraq
was shown live on CNN.
And that was one of
the only channels
that was actually filming.
But you could
never see anything.
It was always dark.
And little lights
would come out.
And you didn't know
what was going on.
It was just like you
could see explosions,
or-- that was a really
important moment,
in terms of discussing and
debating the role of media
and watching war
live on television.
10 years later, there was 9/11.
And I don't know how
old you guys were,
but it was a time when
social media didn't exist.
Most people didn't
have mobile phones.
And if they did
have mobile phones,
they didn't have cameras
on their mobile phones.
So what was much more
the thing of the time
was to have a digital
camera in your bag.
And it was usually
very low resolution.
But it was nevertheless digital.
And that was the early
days of creating media,
in digital form.
So suddenly, 10
years later, here I
am in the middle
of this revolution,
and watching everybody
upload material,
I mean, as fast as I'm talking.
There's already 1,000 videos
that would have been uploaded.
So this whole-- over 20
years, but every decade,
this new platform that
image making reaches
was, for me, really,
really fascinating.
And yes, one of the
things that came out
of all the discourses
and the debates
around photography and image
making and media in general
after 9/11 was that, for
the first time in years,
the power had
changed hands-- where
the citizen-- the ones who
were underneath, or very close,
or watching from buildings
and over windows--
were able to document
what was happening.
The media wasn't there.
[INAUDIBLE] citizens.
And that was a really,
really big moment in history,
in terms of suddenly the citizen
had power that the media didn't
have anymore.
So that hold on the power
and in whose hand is always
at the core, I think, at
the heart of those debates,
especially moments like that.
PROFESSOR: So it
was interesting,
and this is where I speak
about citizen journalism,
and how and why that
moment in Tahrir
was really interesting for me.
Because I had seen this
throughout my career
as a photographer and
artist, and watched that.
And I was really
fascinated with it.
Let's talk about the role of
media in mobilizing people.
So Facebook and
Twitter are often
depicted as the main instruments
of the Arab Revolution,
to the point that the revolution
has been called a social media
revolution, a Facebook
revolution, Twitter revolution.
And apparently, one
of the main elements
that contributed
to this [INAUDIBLE]
uniting the young Egyptians
that were not, as you said,
necessarily into
politics at that time,
was this Facebook page that
we spoke about earlier.
We are all Khaled Saeed.
I know I don't pronounce
it well, but I try.
LARA BALADI: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry about that.
And apparently, this
page was protesting
against the death of this
young blogger after his arrest
by the police.
And it said, even
showing pictures
of his disfigured corpse,
I think, at the beginning,
I guess, maybe.
And according to
the author of one
of the texts that we had
to read today, Gerbaudo,
this page was successful
because it individualized
Facebook interaction.
I think he was talking as if
he was Khaled Saeed, actually,
at the beginning.
And at some point
during the revolution,
apparently it became kind of
a place to collect evidences
against the regime and
against the police brutality,
and a sort of megaphone that
was relaying information
about events that were coming.
And apparently, it also served
to build up the confidence
about the movement.
So my question was,
when did you see
this page for the first time?
And how did it affect
your motivation
to kind of get involved?
And do you believe
that, when you saw that,
did you believe that
it was an important,
a positional movement, that
was kind of rising in Egypt?
Was it the proof that
something was going on?
LARA BALADI: So that's
a nice question,
because I was not on Facebook
when the revolution started.
So I had no idea even, like, why
people even went on Facebook.
It was just I could hear
my friend talk about it.
I was just horrified.
I was like, [INAUDIBLE] there.
So no, I was not on Facebook.
I did not have a
Twitter account.
I didn't even know
Twitter existed.
I knew about Facebook, but--
and I didn't have a television I
still don't.
So my relationship with internet
was a good relationship,
but it wasn't like
a very-- I wasn't
like a freak surfer on the net.
It wasn't like I was spending
hours looking for things,
or using it in ways
that I use it now.
So I wasn't aware of that page.
I remember when Khaled
Saeed was killed,
and I felt something
is about to happen.
And this was maybe 18 months
before the revolution started.
It was in June, 2010.
The revolution started
in January, 2011.
What I can say-- I mean, of
course I saw the page later.
And I think it had an
extraordinary impact.
But I think the
interesting story here,
which-- to go back to
some of the images--
the interesting story here is
how this Facebook page began.
Because we're not talking
about making a Facebook
page and-- this is [INAUDIBLE].
So we're not talking about
making a Facebook page now,
or in a normal
kind of situation,
or in a kind of relatively
normal situation.
I don't know what the
normal situation would be.
We're talking about a Facebook
page under Mubarak regime.
And at the end of
the Mubarak regime,
Amn ad-Dawla, the
State Security,
was incredibly
powerful-- probably
one of the most
powerful securities
for sure in the
region, and probably
across many other
countries in the world.
So you're talking about a very
corrupted time in history,
and a very, very
intense time, where
there is no way anybody could
say who they were or say
anything about the
regime, because they
would be immediately arrested--
let alone on Facebook, which
is a public space, as you know.
So the story goes that
there was the administrator
of Google Egypt, who was in
Dubai for a conference, who's
a young guy who's now
in LA, Wael Ghonim.
And one of the activists of one
of the very small but very new
and probably, obviously,
very important--
that became very important--
political opposition group that
formed itself and called
itself Sixth of April--
formed itself after
the events that
took place in 2010 of all
the workers in the Delta
in the north of
Egypt that rebelled
against the conditions
of how they were working
and how much they
were paid and so on.
And a lot of these
people were killed.
A lot of them were arrested.
It was pretty much-- it was one
of the very important moments
pre-revolution that marked
this real disruption
between the corrupted
regime and the people.
And so after that day,
that group formed itself.
So one of the people
from that group
was in that same conference,
and sat next to Wael Ghonim,
but didn't tell him who he was.
And Wael Ghonim didn't
tell him who he was.
They were just on internet, as
people do it in internet cafe,
or when they have--
like you guys were
at the beginning of the class.
They sort of sit
together, google stuff,
and sometimes talk.
And at one point, one of
them said, how can we get
people to actually participate?
How do we collect people?
How do we bring
people's attention?
What would we do?
And so Wael told him, you know,
let's make this Facebook page.
And you can do this,
and you can do that.
And that's the way that you kind
of attract people's attention.
So I don't know what was
the conversation exactly.
I wish I was there.
I wasn't.
But from that conversation,
and not knowing each other,
and still not knowing
each other afterwards,
that's how they created
this Facebook page.
And people started to join
and like, and like, and like.
And before we knew it,
there was thousands
of people on the page.
And of course, with
the events in Tunis
followed by the
events that started
to escalate in Cairo and
Egypt, the Facebook page
became more and more and more
kind of catalyzer or something
that was about to happen.
So I think that's the
real role of that page.
Now, that page was
essentially addressed
to people who are in the
age range of age of Khaled--
so late '20s.
I don't know what's the
percentage in America,
but in Egypt there is 65% of
the population is below 30 years
old.
That's huge.
We're a very young country.
There's lots of babies
everyday that are born.
So it's like when you're
talking to somebody who's
27 being killed-- imagine the
impact on the similar kind
of people in the population.
So that kind of merging of
moments, events, the fact
that also it's a generation
that, as you know better than I
do, lives on the
internet and knows
internet since they were born--
it was a very natural thing.
So just sort of like
all these elements
kind of contributed for
something to happen.
PROFESSOR: So it
reaches more the youth.
The authors that we
had to read for today,
they seem a bit skeptical about
if the social media were really
motivating people,
mobilizing people.
There's no doubt that they did,
but what was important of it
compared to ground-level
organization?
And so in the tweets
on the street,
Gerbaudo mentioned that
it took a few months
before actually the
Facebook RSVP translated
into massive physical
attendance in public spaces.
And also, the DFK
[INAUDIBLE] from Tunisia.
And he mentioned also that the
Occupy Wall Street Movement
was not magically born
out of a Twitter hashtag,
but gained importance
after a slow process
of ground-level organization.
So I know it's a tough
question, but do you
think that the Egyptian
revolution would
have happened without
the digital technology,
without social media?
And or maybe in a more
easy way to answer,
how important was
the role of Facebook
in recruiting part spent and
mobilizing people, bringing
them to Tahrir Square?
LARA BALADI: I mean, when
it happened-- and this
is why this image actually
is very important,
because suddenly there's
this young woman.
And she's in front
of the police.
To see this in an Arab
country was in itself
an image that shocked people.
Wow, all these women were at the
front line of the revolution.
I mean, they weren't just
standing at the back.
We were actually at the front.
And so to see that, and to see
that generation kind of come
out and not want a revolution.
They didn't come out
asking for a revolution.
They actually came out
asking for dignity.
So please stop the
police from abusing us,
because I don't want
to get into details,
but most people have been
abused by the police,
and sometimes sexually
abused by the police.
So there's a huge
amount of torture
that came out-- a revelation
about how many instruments
were hidden into these caves
of all these police stations.
The context was that you have
to imagine the Khaled Saeed
case leading to
the Facebook page,
leading to bringing all this
generation-- essentially
that generation-- to the
street on the 25 of January.
That was a very
important moment.
And yes, it came
out of universities.
It came out of a new generation
that was kind of like,
why are these older
people not doing anything?
What's wrong with them?
And very quickly, when the whole
thing turned-- very quickly
became violence.
So from the first
night, the police
attacked all these
demonstrators,
even though they were
much less in number.
But they waited, as they
do, because they're cowards.
They waited until
everybody went home.
And then they
attacked when there
was less people in the street.
So that happens,
usually, at midnight.
So then this two
days that followed,
there is more violence that
takes place in the streets.
A few people get killed--
the first martyrs
of the revolution.
And that sort of stated
a kind of enough.
Now that's it.
Those kids went to the streets.
We adults are actually
cowards for not
having done what they're doing.
We've been waiting
for 13 years to even
have the guts to do that.
And they kill people.
And why?
And it's enough.
And so on that Friday, which
was called the Day of Anger,
the whole population went out.
Everybody went out.
Every single per-- and
we're talking the day
where there's no more internet.
There's no more telephones.
There's no more anything.
So everybody went out.
So yes, there was a trigger
that was associated to Facebook.
And people called it
the Facebook revolution
because there was something
really beautiful about it.
There was people who
were young, people
who were courageous,
people who died.
There was a real
desire for change.
There was something
very innocent, and very,
very really very hopeful.
And the shift
happened very quickly
when that whole population
followed, but very quickly
also turned into
who's going to take
advantage of what's happening?
So this kind of unfolds
as the revolution unfolds.
But the role of the social
media at the very beginning
is really a kind of
trigger and a sign
that this need for change
comes from this generation that
wants to have a future.
But then, everybody
else who is politicized
and everybody else who
is part of the society
also has different interest
in things changing or not.
And so then a lot of
other things happened.
And then the media,
as we know, also
take on another role
as everything changes
every minute, and then every
day, every week, and so on,
and so forth.
So yes, it's a very
important role.
But it doesn't
define the society
because it's the trigger of
something at the beginning.
And also it doesn't really--
what this is not addressed also
in that image-- kind of
utopic image-- of watching
all these young people working
towards something they're
dreaming of-- is that most
of the population, especially
people who are in the
countryside, which
has been very ignored
during the revolution,
especially by the
foreign media-- everybody
was focusing on Tahrir.
Tahrir is just a
little area in Cairo.
It's actually not even that big.
And yet there's Egypt.
And Egypt is essentially
countryside and people
who are peasants, or people
who are workers in the delta.
So all of these people are
not necessarily connected
to internet.
They don't have a Facebook page.
So two million people signed
up on Facebook in the first 10,
20 days of when the
internet came back.
So I'm one of them.
So then you have also
this whole relationship
of how people have focused
on that first moment.
And it kind of colored
what happened after.
But no, it's much more
complex than this.
And the economics of the country
is at the core of the movement.
The different religions are
at core in the movement.
There's a lot of other
levels that we can get into.
But it's not the subject today.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
considering the low level
of internet
connection in Egypt--
there was 25% of the population
connected in 2011, according
to the statistic that I saw--
and the low alphabetization
rate-- 65% compared
to 99% in the States.
And the fact that only--
LARA BALADI: So you
found that number?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but--
LARA BALADI: That's huge.
That's amazing.
PROFESSOR: Well, alphabetization
is something subjective.
So I'm pretty sure it's not
99% that read very well.
LARA BALADI: 99 is not bad.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean, so
it was the one beside the 65%.
And only 4% of adults were on
Facebook before the revolution,
so it's not much.
The question is, how did
the techno-savvy youth
manage to bridge the digital
gap, the digital divide,
during the Arab Spring?
And were they employing other
techniques, other means,
to kind of get these
people who were not
connected on the street?
LARA BALADI: I think
that's part of the problem,
is that-- I mean, I
wouldn't associate
that problem to
necessarily-- people
were using the tools they have.
But very quickly, it appeared
that you have community.
It's a little bit like
being in a university.
So you have your
group of people.
You have your community.
You have those do sports with.
You have those you have
the same classes with,
so on, and so forth.
And in a way, they start
talking to each other.
But they're not really
talking to everybody else.
And so suddenly, when
you start-- anyway,
I got on Twitter very
early on-- as soon
as the internet came back.
Because I didn't
have a television.
I had to know what
the hell's going on.
So I tried to figure it out.
I didn't really like Facebook,
but I was, like, wow,
Twitter is pretty cool.
So I really got it very quickly.
And I got really agitated
on Twitter very quickly.
And so I'm, like,
OK, who's important?
Who's saying what?
So you start following
people, and understanding,
and kind of mapping
who's the activists here,
and who's interesting, and
who's saying stupid things,
and who's saying interesting
things, and who's calling
for violence, and who's not.
So it's actually quite funny.
Because it's like this
whole thing is unfolding.
And you have all these
characters without face
that you discover.
And you become part of
that whole film, in a way.
And the interesting thing was
that some of those characters
or activists or
participants were really
focusing on this
notion of organization
or this notion of criticizing
or freely talking.
Because now we could talk.
But there was no sense
of-- I never felt
that they were talking to me.
They were always kind of
talking to one another,
like knowing who was on Twitter.
And they were kind of
talking to each other.
And then the media, after the
18 days that toppled Mubarak,
the international media
was much more present
and able to document
the revolution.
And of course, the
first thing they did
is they transformed people
into heroes and icons
of the revolution.
And yes, some of them were.
Some of those
people were amazing.
And they're still amazing.
But what it did is that
it kind of intensified
the sort of ego of
some of these people.
And it intensified their
importance in a movement,
and kind of blurred the actual
reasons why this was happening,
and kind of almost
disconnected them
from the rest of the society.
And one of the big criticisms
of that generation,
whether it was in Alex, in Suez,
or in Cairo-- doesn't matter--
was that nobody was
addressing the countryside.
Nobody was addressing the
[INAUDIBLE] around Cairo.
actual role of all these people
outside of Tahrir.
Go down the street,
and go to another area.
And see what's going on.
So this became
really problematic,
because the way the focus
became so about the square
and so much about some of
these important activists,
it also created a
kind of disconnection
with the rest of
the communities.
And as young people are--
they're very passionate
and they're very radical, and
sometimes a little bit blinded
by their passion-- so they tend
to kind of obscure themselves
from the possibilities
that-- to be strong,
they need to have
people on their side.
And I think one of
the big mistakes
was that they were
so, so radical
and believed so much and in
a certain way for democracy
to be implemented
that anybody who
didn't believe the same thing,
they kind of dismissed them.
What they forgot
to do is that they
didn't realize that who
they were dismissing
were actually the majority
of people in Egypt.
And so to lose the
majority of people in Egypt
is also what got us
to where we are today.
And that majority said, enough
of this bullshit or mess
in the street that's happening.
And let's go back with at least
having our military regime
taking care of security.
So I think that was one
of the big mistakes,
is that you throw
yourself into a movement,
but then you forget to
bring people in with you.
PROFESSOR: Do you
think-- I read that there
were some tactics to
kind of agitate people
with face-to-face relation.
Like people were
going in the street,
and there were some regimen
points at different places
in working neighborhoods.
And people were meeting
there, and then they
were going down
the street chanting
slogans, positive
slogans, to kind of drive
more people with them walking
towards Tahrir Square.
Do you think that
these kind of tactics
are more efficient than the
Facebook or the digital media
tactics?
Or it's kind of a
combination of both
that makes it more-- that
allowed to reach more
people, more diverse crowd?
LARA BALADI: I think it's all
of-- it's everything together.
It's almost like
it's something--
you have to imagine it
like something climaxing.
So you have all these
things happening,
but you're not really aware,
maybe, that they're happening.
But suddenly, everybody finds
themselves in the same place
and things collide.
And it's that explosion
that's actually incredible.
And that creates that
fascinating time that we lived.
And so it's a combination.
It's like a timing.
It's like a moment where
everybody was ready.
There's maybe some
[INAUDIBLE] I don't know.
But who knows.
But there was a real kind
of an invisible march
towards that time.
And the tactics that where
you were-- of course,
they started on Facebook.
As [INAUDIBLE] Facebook,
which I find out later,
prepares people for
the 25th of January,
saying, go down with an
onion in your pocket,
with a bottle of vinegar,
and with a mask if you can.
And so I found myself
in Tahrir on the Friday,
on the Day of Anger at
10:00 in the morning.
I didn't even know
there was marches
going from these
mosques and all this.
And I just knew everybody
was going to meet in Tahrir.
But I didn't realize there was
a kind of movement that was
going to actually take place.
So I go before
everybody, very early.
Which means that I find myself
in the center of the city
where then, few hours later,
there's already demonstrations.
So people are marching
up and down the streets.
And there's already these
groups of people kind
of occupying the main streets
of the area around Tahrir.
And there's police kind of
blocking the entrance to Tahrir
from the outskirts of the city,
of the center of the city.
And all these marches kind
of come towards the center,
and of course,
confront the police.
But I'm also inside.
So I'm confronting the
police from inside.
It's like a big mess.
And it's really funny.
Because suddenly, I'm, like,
what the hell is going on?
And then boom-- tear gas.
It's horrible.
I don't know if you've
experienced it before.
But you start really coughing
and everything hurts.
And it's really itchy and so on.
And some guy next to you
will give you vinegar
and you wash your
face with vinegar.
And so it's all these
tactics that were
shared on the Facebook page.
But then when you're
on the street,
you're dealing with the street.
You have to react quickly.
And you have to hide
when you have to hide.
And you have to understand
violence very quickly,
and understand where you
stand in all of this.
So it's a mix of always adapting
and having people with you
that everybody
supports each other.
So there's a real
solidarity that's
very natural that takes place.
Because when you have
a very clear enemy,
it's very easy to be
friends with your neighbor.
When you're not sure
who the enemy is,
then everybody's
your enemy, in a way.
So it's a very interesting
time, because it's
very clear who the enemy is.
And so the energy and
the kind of togetherness
is incredibly strong.
And so methods of responding
to the very fast-changing times
that we're living
in those 18 days,
and then a bit
slower as times goes
in the aftermath of
Tahrir, is all about people
finding solutions to everything.
And those solutions
are shared on Twitter.
They're in the street.
And maybe you can
show-- I don't know
where it is in the sildeshow,
but the way Tahrir [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I have photo of this.
LARA BALADI: Yes,
here, the camp.
Can you do it to slideshow?
So this is an image
of [INAUDIBLE]
and how it was organized.
And so at the center
of it, under the tents,
you have the blogger
tent, the media tent.
Then you have an area where you
have the medical part, where
people who were hurt were being
helped by whoever's a doctor,
was actually sudden
improvise themselves
as making a hospital.
And the space in the square
where people could be taken
care of.
On Twitter you
would have suddenly
hashtags of medical supplies and
Tahrir Square-- different types
of names and people improvising
accounts, but also organizing
in little groups.
And saying if you're
going to bring something,
bring it-- let's focus.
Not everybody brings band-aids.
If you want to bring something,
this is what we need.
This is what we need.
And this is what we need.
And this is where we are.
And so you can
start helping people
by following what's going on.
So it's a combination of street
intelligence and communication
online, and communication
between people.
So it's a very fast-moving
time and vary fascinating,
because it really plays
out on so many layers.
PROFESSOR: There's
kind of an interaction
between organizing
on the ground,
organizing in the social media.
I want to switch
subject and talk
a bit about the
role of social media
for bringing the world
attention to the cause.
There's no doubt that Facebook,
YouTube, Flickr, Twitter
facilitated the citizen
journalism, helped
desseminating the news,
showing the police
brutality to the
world, eliciting
international attention.
And similarly, the activists
involved in the Occupy Movement
creatively used social media
and cutting-edge technology
like live streaming
to kind of bring
the world attention to the
encampment and to the cause
itself.
And both movements
really managed
to secure an impressive
degree of public support.
In your article, "When
Seeing is Belonging"--
I'm referring to it a lot.
I really liked it.
You mentioned that the
image of Tahrir Square
circulating on the
web and in the news,
and I quote, "Turn all
established cliches of Egypt
on their heads."
And I really like this idea.
And I would like to ask you how
exactly did these images change
the world perception of Egypt?
LARA BALADI: It feels so
old already, and sadly so,
because of what's
happening now with ISIS
and all this horrible stuff.
But at the time,
if you remember,
2011-- this is like
10 years after 9/11.
And there's been this
whole War on Terror
and this whole really-- I
mean, it's not new from 9/11,
but it's multiplied.
And it grew
exponentially after 9/11,
that whole visible
of the Arab world,
and putting everybody
into an Arab
is a Muslim and
Muslim is a terrorist.
And it's like this
kind of generalization
of what the Arab world is.
So one of the cliches was-- I
should have put this picture,
but it doesn't matter--
but one of the first things
that kind of comes
up is suddenly,
the dirty Arab-- the
terrorists-- is not a terrorist
anymore.
He's actually a revolutionary.
And he's working for
peace in the world.
And he wants change and
he wakes everybody up.
The whole world was stuck
to their television looking
at Tahrir.
It was one of the
most [INAUDIBLE],
and still is until today.
So that was one thing.
Then, if you remember, there was
the Wisconsin actually happened
more [INAUDIBLE] time of Tahrir.
And one of the funniest
images that came out
was this woman holding a
banner saying, Egypt, help us.
So from America being very
anti-Arabs and anti-terrorists
and anti- anything that
comes out of the Arab world,
you have this kind of
like calling for help
from-- we actually are friends.
And we think the same way.
And we discovered that
maybe we can get along.
So this was really interesting.
And of course, to go back to
photography, and to my interest
as an artist and
the medium that I
use in making images, what
happens-- not so much in the 18
days as much as
just after 18 days,
the whole period, the aftermath
after Mubarak is toppled
is also to watch
how I've experienced
Egypt all my life
as a kid, and all
my life as an adult
with this relationship
it has with the West,
and with tourism,
and how Egypt has always
been a place where-- I'm sure
all of you have
studied ancient Egypt
when you were 11 years
old, more or less.
So that's in every
schoolbook in the world,
you have ancient Egypt more or
less at the age of nine or 11,
something like this.
So it's the first
fascination with the world.
And it's the first civilization.
And everybody wants
to see the Pyramids.
But here we go.
We're like, we have Tahrir.
And this pyramids, which
here is not a cliche.
It's actually another way of
looking at the Pyramids-- which
itself takes away the cliche
of the idea that these Pyramids
are unobtainable-- gets
replaced by the birds-eye view
of Tahrir.
And after the 18 days,
you start watching
all of these Western people that
come and do tourism in Tahrir,
and don't want to
see the revolution,
want to be part of it.
So you have people
who are activists.
You have people who
are just people who are
fascinated by what's happening.
They want to be part of it.
They just come.
And so you see this new
kind of tourism evolve,
and Egypt becoming associated
with the revolution, Tahrir,
people, et cetera, et cetera.
And no one's talking
about the Pyramids.
I'm not even sure anybody's
even going to see them.
And I'm not sure how
long that's going
to take for them to come back.
But I think it's a very
interesting sort of shift,
and how overnight, that image
that's been there for centuries
gets kind of deleted, and
replaced by this other Egypt
that we're in the
middle of at the moment.
PROFESSOR: I will definitely
visit Tahrir Square if I go.
LARA BALADI: You'll
be sadly disappointed,
but I can still take
you to the Pyramids.
PROFESSOR: All right,
I'd like to talk
a little bit about the role of
social media as an alternative
to commercial media.
Earlier in the
semester, we learned
that a few media companies own
the majority of the world's
media outlets.
And with Herman
and Chomsky, we saw
that this was a problem,
like a threat to democracy,
because the mass media tend
to construct a worldview that
conforms to the need of
corporate advertisement,
valorising some
political perspective
and marginalizing
other perspectives.
And in this context, a lot of
people see internet as a space
where counter-hegemonic point
of view can be expressed.
And in countries like
Egypt, the situation
is even worse,
since the media are
controlled by the government
and subjected to censorship.
Actually, that's more a
question than an affirmation.
How biased was the Egyptian
coverage of the revolution?
And to what extent all
these events happening
were censored by the regime
in the mass media in Egypt?
LARA BALADI: I want to
maybe answer this and look
a little bit-- can we
come out of the slideshow
so we see a little bit?
[INAUDIBLE] So
yeah, it's a joke.
It's propaganda, but old-style.
It's like grotesque.
Grotesque-- you know that word?
So it's really ridiculously--
it's one big lie.
And it's sadly almost funny.
It's dark humor at that point.
And when the revolution
starts, nothing really changes.
I mean, actually
people who did not
want to continue to
participate to that lie
left their jobs at
the state media.
And the state media continues
to have a huge amount of power,
because of what I was
saying earlier, is
that most people actually
don't have internet.
A lot of people do, but a
lot of people still don't.
And a lot of people
believe in their army.
I mean, why we're back
in the military regime
is because Egypt has
a relationship that's
a little bit incestuous
with their army.
We have an army
that is not really
that interested in keeping
the country protected
from potential external enemies,
as much as we have an army that
is there to control us.
But that army is made of us.
So every single family in
Egypt has at least two or three
people that are in the army.
So nobody wants their army to
be at war, either with them
or with anybody
else, because that
would be their
son, their father,
their brother could
be endangered.
However, the army and the
regime control the media.
And so at one point in the
evolution of the events,
and the continuation of the
role of the army post-Mubarak
being toppled-- so we go
from Mubarak to having
the rule of the SCAF--
the Supreme Council
of Armed Forces,
which is the army.
We have a whole series of
events that take place.
And one of them is a
very terrible massacre
that happens in October, 2011
in front of the state media--
Maspero-- this huge building
that is on the Nile in Cairo,
where the media is broadcasted.
And there's a
demonstration because a lot
of-- at the time, a lot
of Christian churches
are being attacked.
This is a period for
months and months
and months where we don't
have police in the country,
in the city, and nowhere.
So we were very happy, actually.
But there was still a
lot of little crime,
given that there is no police.
So of course there
is going to be crime.
But these crimes
happening in upper Egypt
lead to these demonstrations
to ask for the Supreme
Council of Armed Forces to
protect the Christians in Egypt
who are a minority.
That demonstration leads to
the army actually rolling
over people.
And the whole
thing is atrocious.
People get rolled over.
The photos-- I
can't even tell you
the horrible photos that
surfaced on Facebook
and whatever.
Lots of people died.
It was really, really ugly.
And of course, the army
goes on TV and says,
oh, but we don't
use live ammunition.
We don't actually
We didn't do anything.
And so this graffiti
says [ARABIC] liars.
And it has the army cap.
So [ARABIC] becomes
a movement where
people do sort of
video flash mobs
in the streets projecting
videos of martyrs and others
at very impromptu
moments in the street,
saying the army is lying to you.
And this is in a
popular area of Cairo.
PROFESSOR: And what
about the American media?
Because we saw in the course
that the American media tend
to be very biased,
especially when
they cover
international politics.
And we know that the States were
supporting the Mubarak regime
to a certain extent
before the revolution.
So were the American media
also biased, very biased,
or where they more fair
during the revolution?
LARA BALADI: I don't
know if [ARABIC] is--
what [ARABIC] is-- this one.
Do you know what this child is?
PROFESSOR: Anybody
recognize where this is?
LARA BALADI: I'm not sure
where is it from, but--
AUDIENCE: It's Russia.
LARA BALADI: It is, right?
So this is quite funny,
because with your text.
PROFESSOR: Let's talk about
the role of social media
in organizing the protests.
So we often refer
to-- the scholars
often refer to social media
as a means to coordinate
gatherings, road
blockage, protests,
other forms of actions on the
ground during the Arab Spring
and the Occupy Movement.
Apparently Facebook was used
to set the date of events.
Twitter was used to connect
people across distance
and to share logistics
in real time.
As you said earlier, you have
to react quickly on the ground.
So sometimes Twitter was saying
this is the rallying point.
This is the location
where the police is.
This is the things
we need, the medicine
we need for-- because
there were people injured.
And Gerbaudo uses the
expression "choreography
of assembly" to describe
the role of social media
in facilitating the
physical assembly of highly
dispersed individuals, as
well as the scene setting
and scripting.
So how did you use, yourself,
the social media as a means
to organize your day,
where you're going to go,
what you're going to do
during the revolution?
LARA BALADI: I mean,
again, I wasn't
a Facebook, Twitter person.
So I was using it more to kind
of know what was going on,
and to make sure I wouldn't
miss something dangerous
or something I
should know about.
So it was very-- and
actually, for a little while,
I always felt a little bit late.
Like, I always felt
like I'm really
sure what's going on here.
I spent a lot of time
trying to make sense of it.
And in retrospect,
talking to people,
everybody was in
that same situation.
Because no one really was
expecting this to happen.
So everyone was trying to figure
out who was who in all of this.
Who's doing this, actually?
Is there somebody doing this,
or where is this coming from?
So there was a sense of
first understanding minute
by minute where you stand.
Because this is
also where I live.
This is my life.
So for four years, I lived in
the middle of-- I mean, one
night, one day-- I don't
know what time it was.
It was maybe 11:00
PM or something.
And I live-- the Nile
is not so far from me.
And on the other
side of the Nile
is a whole area that
is called Imbabah.
And it's a popular area.
It very, very, populated.
And Cairo is 7 million people.
So it's a very, very dense
population and dense city.
And I live in an area where
there's a lot embassies
and schools.
And it's between two
branches of the Nile.
And so on one side is
Tahrir and on the other side
is other areas of Cairo.
So I could walk to Tahrir.
But at the same time,
I was across the Nile.
So there was a sense of,
also a feeling of security.
People actually
moved back to where
I lived, because it was
almost the safest place to be
in Cairo, in that period.
But all of a sudden
at 11:00 PM, I get up.
And I'm, like, what the
hell is going on here?
And I look down at every
window from my house.
And I've never seen this.
All these tanks are just driving
super-fast in every street,
and heading towards this area.
And I mean, this was never seen.
You never saw this.
Or wake up in the morning
and go to my kitchen.
And I'm about to go to Tahrir.
It's really early.
We're still in the 18 days.
And I look at my window,
like, what's going on here?
And I see the building across
the Nile that is burning.
So this whole area is burning.
And that was the Day of Anger.
Also, the following days
after the Day of Anger,
everything had been
looted and so on.
So it was constantly like
negotiating the danger zones,
the moments where you should
be in the street, the moments
where you shouldn't, what you're
ready to go through or not.
I wasn't necessarily
ready to get killed.
It wasn't really-- I don't think
it was a smart thing to do.
So for me, Twitter,
much more than Facebook,
was really a way of making
sure I would know what
the kind of tension-- where we
were at in the tension scale.
And so it was very interesting,
because I was always
in the Square.
But I also always was
aware that, oh, the army's
coming in half an hour.
We're going to
get into a battle.
Tonight, there's
going to be a sucker.
And this would happen.
So before this would
happen, I would just go home
and say, I'm not going
to get into this.
So it was really
interesting to watch also
that movement on that.
But it was also very confusing,
because some people were also
acting from the spur of the
moment and a bit of hysteria.
And so not everything was real.
And not everything
was true that was
being spread on social media.
So it's this whole constant
kind of figuring out
what is real, what is not.
Is it really happening?
Who's there?
Someone you trust?
Try to get somebody on
Twitter that you think
will not be talking bullshit.
And then you have, also, groups
that form themselves according
to how the events unfold.
And so some of them are focusing
on giving you the right news.
Some of them are
focusing on giving you
information about what
medical supplies are needed.
Some of them are organized.
And this was really incredible.
Much later in the game,
we had a huge amount
of sexual harassment in Tahrir.
So you have this amazing
crowd, especially
of women, that got together--
and young women-- that
got together to
organize bodyguards,
and people who would help
people go through the square
without being sexually harassed.
Of course, they got
sexually harassed themselves
following that.
So it was pretty crazy.
But you had this amazing
amount of energy of people
really putting themselves
together, and coming in groups,
and creating a different
support system.
So this is really
fascinating, in how
people used social media.
And that way was
really beautiful.
PROFESSOR: The
authors that we had
to read for today, they
seem to be convinced
that the most successful
movements are always driven
by face-to-face relation,
on-the-ground organization,
not only by social media.
And moreover, they
would go as far
as saying that, when we put
all our energy on building
websites, innovative software,
technological infrastructure,
we're taking away the focus
from building more movement
and alliance on the
ground, and connecting,
like making real relationship
with local communities.
It may be more accurate
for the Occupy Movement.
And there's also this idea
that the virtual proximity
that we can experiment
online doesn't compare
to the community feeling,
the body density,
of the protest
camps where people
eat, sleep together, defend
their territories together.
So there's this
proximity of the bodies.
I don't know how
you feel about this.
Do you think it's
important to keep
this face-to-face interaction
and physically occupy
a space during a revolution?
Or a revolution can
only happen online?
LARA BALADI: I don't know.
I'm not a specialist in
organizing revolutions.
But I mean, I don't know.
I mean, it's--
PROFESSOR: Maybe a more
easy question for you,
because it's kind of
abstract, but did,
at some point in the
revolution, Tahrir
became a kind of
coordination platform
more than social media?
Meaning like you could get
information on the ground?
LARA BALADI: No, no, of course.
It was very different what
happened on the ground
and what you could--
depending on-- I
mean, if you are somebody on
Twitter since two or three
years, I think
you would probably
have a much more understandable
kind of map of actions, events.
And you would probably
have been aware
of the Facebook
page of Khaled Saeed
and so on, much more before
all of this would start.
So if you're part of that
generation, or a journalist,
again-- were the
main two categories
of people that used
Twitter, for example.
I'll leave Facebook
out for a while.
You would be really aware
of which kind of people
have an interesting
perception of the events,
and how to negotiate that.
And then on the
ground, you would
be, therefore, definitely
magnetized or attracted
by different areas
in the square,
and where people were
organized, or understand better
the kind of actual mapping of
the ground of the picture I
showed you where you can see
the bloggers and all of this.
I mean, as far as I'm
concerned, it was kind of weird.
Because I lost my phone very--
not only there was no internet,
but I also lost my
phone, like two,
three days after the
whole thing started.
And of course, every
shop was closed,
so I couldn't get a new
phone for a few days.
So I really wanted a phone just
to call my mother in Lebanon
and just make sure
she wouldn't worry.
But I was completely
disconnected
from my normal, daily life.
And I ended up being
much more connected
to people on the streets, and
knowing people on the street,
and figuring out how
the square is organized,
and participate with that.
I think your question can
be answered by yes and no,
because we're talking 18 days
where something very specific,
where people really
conglomerated
to Tahrir-- and in Alex
and every other city.
We're always talking
about Tahrir,
but there is the rest of Egypt.
But something, again,
in that period,
you have a very clear enemy and
you have a very careful goal.
But then afterwards, it's
a very different situation.
And then so the negotiations
that happened on the street
or online are a very
different kind of-- they've
become very different
in terms of the dynamics
and how they influenced
what happens.
So there were periods where
Facebook and Twitter were
at the front of what you needed
to look at to really know
what was happening.
So I would say this was for sure
the case during the 18 days.
At the later stage,
there was much more focus
between foreign media, local
media and social media.
So it was really covered by
everybody and everything.
And that was like a
total concentration
of media from all directions.
And less action on the streets,
because the sit-in finished.
Some people stayed,
but not the majority.
And then you have
other waves, where
there's much more
analysis going on,
where the politics
on the ground are not
as violent, or not as
regularity violent,
or not as regularly intense.
But what happens online
is extraordinary.
And you have like 100
people talking, every day
writing blogs, and so on.
Plus, television becomes
occupied by talking heads.
And it's talking
heads, talking heads.
There was two years
of talking heads,
of people finally talking.
And so it's analysis.
So what's going on?
What do you think is going on?
What do you think
is going to happen?
What do you think of these guys?
What do you think of
the Muslim Brotherhood?
What do you think of the army?
And we could say
anything we wanted.
We just didn't realize we
wouldn't have that much time
to continue to do so.
But it was quite an
extraordinary period.
And so again, it's
this kind of power
of what has more power
at a different moment
than another moment?
And so it's also,
again, a kind of balance
between how social media is
influential, or how media is,
or how being on the ground is.
And there was a
very clear moment
where people said, you
know, it doesn't do anything
to go to Tahrir anymore.
We have to go back home.
And we have to do the real work.
And the real work is change very
fundamental aspects and values
within society.
It's not going to the
street and rebelling.
Rebelling is important, but
then you have to follow up.
And follow up means you
have to educate people.
You have to work with them.
You have to get involved
in your communities.
You have to act directly with
people that are your neighbors.
And that can take
10 years, 20 years.
And not everybody wants to spend
that kind of time doing that.
So that's, again,
another subject.
But that's the
kind of landscape.
PROFESSOR: I want to make
sure we have time to talk
about your current work.
So we can go more quickly
on the next questions.
In the book we had to
read, Digital Rebellion,
there's the one
problematic aspect
of the contemporary activism
that was underlined.
It is the difficulty to
connect with local struggle,
local communities, people
from the working class.
So we said this before.
But also, the fact
that these movements
are using the new technologies
and internet so much that it
tends to favor the leadership
of white, male, college-educated
activists at the expense
of homeless people,
unemployed, women, people
of color, indigenous.
was it also the case in Egypt?
How diversified was the
crowd on Tahrir Square?
Were there, like, people from
very different background,
women and men?
Or they were more favoring men?
LARA BALADI: So in the 18
days, it was very different.
Everybody remembers the 18
days as something unique,
and then there's the rest.
But during the 18
days, of course,
it was mainly occupied
by all these young people
that were on Facebook and did
this Khaled Saeed page, and so
on, and who were coming out
of universities, and so on.
But there was also a
majority of population
from every kind of-- every city,
every area of Cairo, from Alex.
People were very diverse,
people who were in the square.
But there was a kind of attitude
that was very particular
during those 18 days.
And again, I think it has to
do with the clarity of who
you're fighting.
And so nobody complained
of sexual harassment
in those 18 days.
Although I think
I'm sure there was.
But I mean, it
wasn't like-- there
was something that
held people together,
because it was so dramatic.
And it was so-- we didn't
know what's going to happen.
And we knew that if this fails,
we'll all end up in jail.
So it couldn't fail.
It's too late.
We've gone already too far.
And actually, everybody
is in jail now.
Most of the people
who were really,
really at the front of--
like obvious activists
are, for a lot of them,
either in jail, or not even.
There's thousands of people
that have been arrested.
And the others have
left the country
because they've been
threatened to be arrested.
So you have a real
escape of intellect
as it happens in
those situations.
But the general sense
is that, in the 18 days,
you have very clear objective.
And everybody's together
towards that objective.
So nobody hurts anybody.
And time hasn't come
yet to divide people.
So it's much later,
after Mubarak is toppled,
that suddenly
everybody is like, OK,
so who's going to
be in power now?
So I want the power.
No, I want the power.
So there's this kind of--
now society gets divided.
And people remove their masks.
30 years, maybe
actually 60 years,
where the guy who sells
the tomatoes downstairs,
or the man who you buy
your bread from-- you
don't know what he thinks.
You don't know who he is.
You know he's Muslim, or you
know he's maybe a little bit
conservative.
But you're not sure-- you
don't care, even, what he is.
I mean, personally,
I don't care.
But suddenly, after the 18 days,
I know this guy is a Salafi.
And then this guy is
a Muslim Brotherhood.
This guy is against the Sadat.
I mean, everybody becomes
who they really are.
And they're not afraid of
showing who they really are.
So the beards grew.
Also, the young people like
you started to have beards.
And I was, like, why is
everybody growing a beard?
And I started asking
everybody, like, OK, I
get it that Muslim Brotherhood
will have their beards,
because they've been arrested
for the last 30 years
and they've been in jail
for the last 30 years.
So, but why you,
my friend, why--
I know you are not the
Brotherhood, so why
are you growing your beard?
What's up with this
bloody fashion?
And they're like, well,
when you're young,
in your early 20s,
30s, the police
arrest you systematically
if you're a man
and you have a little
bit of a beard.
So actually every
young guy in the street
let their beards grow,
because finally, they
were not harassed by the
police for being maybe
a Brotherhood or maybe not.
So it's really interesting
to watch this happen.
And of course, when
the military came back
after the Brotherhood
took power and so on,
it was this joke
on Facebook, which
was the Bic-- the company
Bic that sells razors--
is going to make a fortune.
Because everybody's going
to have to shave again,
which is what happened.
Nobody has a beard now.
You don't want to
have a beard now.
It's not a good place for that.
PROFESSOR: I want to talk a bit
about the role of social media
as a emotional conduit.
I think you had a video
about that somewhere.
So it's clear that social media
cannot be reduced to a purely
instrumental tool for
organization and tactical
coordination.
It also participates, as
Gerbaudo says in his text,
to assemble a construction of
a collective identity, a sense
of togetherness, as
you said earlier,
among activists, physical
occupiers, and internet users.
And this is kind of
clear with the page
of "We are all Khaled
Saeed", but also
with-- if I can find it--
the Tumblr page blood
page of Occupy Movement
that was kind of collecting
different testimonies of
people who consider themselves
as the 90%, 99%,
kind of as a rallying
point for the construction of
inclusive popular identity.
And this moment was really
appealing to everybody.
So do you think
that social networks
serve as an emotional conduit
that condense sentiment
of indignation, anger,
pride, victimhood?
The other example that
the Facebook page,
"We are all Khaled
Saeed," [INAUDIBLE]
maybe show about that?
This one-- oh, we
show it already.
LARA BALADI: Yeah,
that was with the army.
PROFESSOR: But did you
feel that in the end,
the Facebook page
was really canalizing
feelings and generating people?
LARA BALADI: I mean, we are
in a world that is not just
a generation of 25 years old.
But we're in a world
where we all use internet,
and we all use our computers.
We all use social media-- I
mean, the majority of people
does.
And we are also at a time
when after-- again, I
repeat-- after 30
or maybe 60 years,
even, of a military regime, you
have a little bracket of time
where everybody's
allowed to talk.
And so imagine the avalanche
of information that we get.
So from not being able
to do anything-- talk,
take photos in the streets
without being harassed
by some kind of policeman
that is in civil clothes--
or by a sign that says
"Do not take photos here
because it's a military
base," because Egypt
is owned by the military.
So every street is
military base, really.
You have from that situation,
you have a complete shift
overnight to everybody
can say who they are.
Everybody can say
what they think.
And so everybody does.
And in fact, it was
pretty amazing and magical
and very creative.
It was a very, very
creative period
where people were allowed to
be the best of themselves.
And they were.
And so the random citizen
became the biggest artist.
Suddenly, overnight you
had this amazing video,
very funny or maybe very
powerful or very emotional
or very poignant that would be
posted on the net or on Twitter
or whatever, and would
communicate something.
And people, again, created not
just with a hashtag or not just
with a Facebook page, but
they created communities.
And so you have
thousands of websites
that were born from the
merging of people to collect.
So for example, you
have-- this can kind of
go into the work I'm doing now.
But you had suddenly
a group that organized
to collect all the papers,
transcripts, messages
that were circulating
every day in Tahrir,
according to what was happening.
And this is, in itself,
an extraordinary amount
of documents.
And so they would
take these documents,
and scan them, and
put them on the net.
And so this is a website
called TahrirDocuments
where you can go
and you can see,
according to the date,
what was being circulated,
what was available in the
square, what people were giving
each other, handing out.
So you have a great
community-- a number
of communities that have
archived different aspects
of the revolution.
You have people
who have created,
of course a lot of a music
came out of the revolution.
This was one of
the biggest outcome
of the first couple of months.
You really had a huge
amount of creativity.
And in a way, this is what I
was telling you-- it's kind
of the difference between
activists, artists, activism,
also people doing art, but
in an activist kind of way,
and not necessarily in a kind
of contemporary art kind of way.
So it's more something that
is using creativity as a tool,
but as a tool to
fight back, to answer
something that is happening.
So there was a whole
lot of expression
and ways of expressing
oneself that
was born from the first few
months of the revolution.
I'm not sure I'm answering
you, but I think--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
just I don't want
to go too far on
what we're going
to talk later about your work.
So let me just ask
you this question
about the logic of Orientalism
of the Cyber Left movement.
Because all these new
activist movements,
like Occupy,
Anonymous, Arab Spring
and even Indymedia before,
they claim to be a movement.
They present himself as a
direct [INAUDIBLE] democracy
with a preference for horizontal
structure instead of vertical.
So basically, they say they
don't have any leaders.
They don't do elections.
Everybody's a leader, kind of.
And then the authors
of the text that we
had to read for today-- they
claim that these movements were
not as leaderless-- as
flat-- as they claim.
And I'm curious to know if it's
the same feeling that you have.
Gerbaudo used the
concept of choreographer
to describe the kind of
soft form of leadership
that took place during
these movements-- people who
kind of are Facebook admins,
Tweets or bloggers, who
set this stage but without being
in the forefront, people who
orchestrate the, for example,
the Occupy Wall Street
advertising campaign that was
really carefully organized.
So you see that there
are some brains emerging
in these movements.
Do you have any
example of soft leaders
that were organizing the stage?
I know that there were some
bloggers that were maybe having
a bigger influence.
LARA BALADI: I mean, there's a
whole culture of bloggers that
was born in the
Middle East, I think
very much after
2006 war in Lebanon
and the influence of how people
used internet at the time.
And so they created a kind of
community across the region,
not just in Egypt.
And so of course, there's some
very influential people online.
Hamalawi is one of
them, because he
is the one who-- he's
a [INAUDIBLE] activist
who is also a photographer.
And he documented 6 of April,
2008 Mahala demonstrations
that I was describing
earlier, which
then led to the
group that became
opposing the power--
the 6 of April movement.
So Hamalawi, for example,
was documenting already
in 2008 those movements.
Because he works a lot
with workers in Egypt.
And he blogged already three
years before the revolution
that so revolution
will be Flickr-ized.
And his statement was
that if we take photos,
and if we manage to document
what is actually happening,
and posting it, and making
people see what is happening,
then there will be a movement
that will come out of it.
And again, this was countering
the media propaganda, which was
not showing any of this stuff.
We all knew it, but not
really, but kind of.
So of course, there was
very important people who
were doing the work already.
It's not like it
happened overnight.
But they were not--
they were activists.
They were not trying
to take power.
And a lot of them, they
didn't know how to take power.
And it's not what they do.
PROFESSOR: Some of them
became micro-celebrities
against their own will, right?
LARA BALADI: Yeah, I mean,
they were happy to be.
PROFESSOR: They
tried to be modest.
LARA BALADI: No one refuses
to be a celebrity, I think.
It's kind of a human thing.
But these people are not--
because they're activists,
they are not politicians.
It's not because
you in the street
that you're a revolutionary.
It's not because
you are an activist
that you understand politics.
It's not because you are an
artist that you necessarily
do good art.
So these things are not simple.
And it's great to
have a movement.
But where it fails is that there
is no handing over that moment
that we have a little bit of
power, but it's very fragile.
And we let go of that very
fragile shift that can happen.
And instead of giving
the lead to someone
who actually understands
politics, and is
able to take over the role of a
part in a political party that
could hold together a country
like Egypt that has 90
million people, I mean, insane.
Instead of that, you watch
people disagreeing and ego
fighting.
And something very
important is that the nature
of a revolution, and the nature
of dictatorship-- so Egypt
or anywhere in the world--
a dictatorship by nature
is to dictate to eliminate
anybody opposing them.
So there is no
actual opposing power
in place during a dictatorship.
And that was true
during Mubarak regime.
So there was a political
party called the Kefaya.
Kefaya means enough.
And they were really
fighting almost alone
and always being put in jail and
out, and put in jail and out.
And they were pretty upset,
because no one really
talked about them when
the revolution started,
but they were the only
ones really fighting
the regime for the seven years
that preceded the revolution.
And then you had the
6 of April movement,
which was relatively
new-- three years--
but still not so public.
And they were preparing a
revolution for September 2011,
because they had gone to, I
think, the Republic of Czech
and been trained in
different parts of the world
where there had been peaceful
revolutions, that had actually
succeeded.
But that was a plan just
before the next election
where Mubarak was going
to put his son in power.
So when this happened,
there was no plan.
We didn't go to the streets
saying, we want the revolution.
There was no plan to
hand the power over,
to have somebody ready to
take power if that would work.
So--
PROFESSOR: Would you say that--
LARA BALADI: That's
where the gap sort of--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because
the authors that we read,
they kind of argue that
these leaderless movements,
they don't allow to make
proactive decisions,
build long-term
powerful organization.
And not investing in
leadership will eventually
lead to the dismantle
of these movements.
LARA BALADI: Yes, that happened.
PROFESSOR: You think the
revolution would have benefited
from having stronger leaders
to take responsibility
for some failure or some--
LARA BALADI: Yes,
of course it would.
But the problem was
that there was nobody.
And everybody who tried was
rejected by everybody else
for many reasons.
So even Baradei, who
came back to Egypt
three years before
Mubarak left, was not
liked by the
Egyptian population,
because he's lived
20 years abroad.
And also for a very
good reason, which is
he was one of the actors
that had influenced the Gulf
War, the Iraq War in 2003 by
being the one who was appointed
to give the answer on
whether or not there
was nuclear weapons in Iraq.
And he said yes.
We never found any.
But you know, what the
consequences of that
is terrible.
And so of course people
don't forget that.
So when he came and
said, hello, I'm
going to be the next
president, of course everybody
said excuse me?
Who are you?
So that was the
case for everybody
who presented
themselves as a leader.
So even the Brotherhood,
even everybody
who-- but who can be ready when
there's a dictatorship that
does not-- that puts
people in jail if they say,
I'm going to present myself
at the next election.
Next thing you know
is they're arrested
or they have to
leave the country.
So that's the nature
of dictatorship.
So you're surrounded by a wall.
You need to break the wall.
And you don't know
what's behind the wall.
And you're not ready
to go behind the wall.
But you have no other choice.
That's the first step.
You need to break that wall.
So we broke the wall.
We're back into
another movement.
But now we know what's going on.
And now we know what's going on.
And things will not
be the way they were.
It might take more time.
And it's a very different
battle that will prepare itself.
But it's a necessity to
go through these steps.
PROFESSOR: So we don't have
much time left-- ideally,
10 minutes.
LARA BALADI: That's OK.
We talked.
Everybody had enough, I think.
PROFESSOR: No, but we want to
talk about your current work,
because it's very interesting.
And the obsession of
scholars for the role
played by Twitter and Facebook
during the revolution kind
of eclipsed a very interesting
conversation that we
can have about the role
of traditional media
in the revolution.
And since you're the co-founder
of a radio and a cinema,
during the revolution,
I think you're the best
person to talk about this.
So can you talk a little--
LARA BALADI: Just
traditional media?
PROFESSOR: Yes, cinema and
radio are traditional media
compared to digital media.
So can you talk briefly
about these two initiatives
before we talk about
your project [INAUDIBLE]?
LARA BALADI: Sure.
So again, I'm an artist.
And when all this started,
I watch this amazing stuff
come out of nowhere by
people producing music, films
and so on.
And I watched one video
that really fascinated me,
which triggered this
kind of interest
for what was
happening every day.
What I was experiencing
was resonating with events
that I remembered
from my childhood--
which I didn't live, but
I remember watching on TV
and being very impressed by.
So that first video of
a truck and somebody
standing in front of the
police truck, the water cannon,
but not going anywhere.
He would just stay there.
And so the police goes
backwards, which is incredible.
And it's one of the
first videos of courage
that appears and
viral on YouTube.
And it was posted
on YouTube, and it
was called [ARABIC]
Courage Video or something.
And so this connection
with the history,
with another event
from '89 in China
of-- if you remember
this video, if you know
this video of this man standing
in front of an Army tank
and not moving, and the
whole world watching
20 tanks kind of going
towards this man--
triggered the need for
me to see and understand
what's happening in relationship
to history in the world,
not just to Egypt
and Egyptian history.
And so I started collecting
things, and archiving videos
and just learning, and
collecting, and organizing,
and so on.
And one of the first
things I did was-- I
didn't want to do any art work.
That was not the time for
me to do any art work.
But in the square, I
met a lot of people.
And with a friend of
mine during the 18 days,
we wanted to do a
free radio so that we
could connect ourselves.
And the 18 days ended.
Mubarak was toppled
and so on, but we still
wanted to do the radio.
So suddenly, it was not
just my friend and I.
It was actually this guy next
to me wants to do the radio.
And then he knows this guy who
also wants to work with him.
And then this person
is doing this.
And it was very organic.
And before I knew it, we
were a whole group of people.
And we created this radio.
So it was very spontaneous.
And it was a lot of--
there's one very funny show
of two characters
making fun of politics.
And then there was a lot of
music from the revolution.
So we were kind of a receptacle
for all this music production
during that period.
Following that--
that's another image.
Following that, a
few months later,
I realized that
most people probably
hadn't seen all these
animation videos
like the one I showed you,
that most people weren't
on internet, that actually, not
everybody had seen what really
happened in the 18 days.
And we were, again,
doing a sit-in in Tahrir.
So I decided I have
to use the archive
that I started building.
And I have to show
this to people.
And there's a sit-in
that's starting.
And I know it's going
to take a long time.
And I'm not going to
sit there in the square
and not do anything.
And actually, there's
no images in the square.
So we need to
focus on something.
People need to see something.
So I decided to
make a cinema, but I
wasn't sure what and
how-- all of this.
And then I'm on Twitter, and
I see somebody saying, oh, we
should project films.
I was, like, oh, he
wants to do that, too.
So I connected with him.
And then somebody else said,
oh, you want to do cinema.
I know your work.
I've seen your work.
I don't know what.
Are you going to show your work?
I said, of course I'm not
going to show my work.
This is like the
middle of a revolution.
Who cares about seeing my work?
But let's get together
and talk about it.
And so we created the
cinema and the sit-in.
And every night, we
projected material
that was circulating
on the internet,
but that most probably,
most people didn't see.
And it created a
space for a platform
for debating the revolution,
a platform for convening
and sharing the archive.
So people would come
with their phone and say,
can you give me a
copy of what you show?
Because I can show
this in my area.
I can show this to
the coffee next door,
project it in the
street next to my house.
I can show it to my family.
I can bring to my village.
And I can give
you what I filmed.
And so it was a way of
exchanging material and kind
of disseminating, also,
on the ground, footage
from the revolution that
was countering the media
propaganda that was happening.
So these are some images of the
crowds in the square watching
the footage.
PROFESSOR: For the
last five minutes,
let's talk about your
project on the archiving
the revolution, because
it's also a concern that we
should have with digital media.
LARA BALADI: We
even have popcorn.
Yeah, so these are
the two projects
that I've done as the first
sort of actions or outcome
of collecting material,
and feeling like,
to make sense of all of this,
because of the collage that you
saw originally, you can
imagine how my head works.
And I have to have
lots of stuff,
and make connections
and all this.
So it doesn't
happen immediately.
It takes a little bit of
time to find these links.
And same thing here.
I just felt there's no
conclusion to be made now.
But all these
questions are popping
every minute in my head.
So my collection of
archive was really
about keeping this for when
I'll be able to think about it,
and when there will be a
moment where things start
to kind of come down and
I can make sense of it
and find a link that holds it
all together-- if there is one.
I don't know.
And so now my project
here is about looking
at that period of
two, three years,
and trying to build a timeline
of the revolution that
is interactive.
So this is an example of a
very fantastic, beautiful,
visual timeline of the
history of the world.
Which this part is
about ancient Egypt,
as you see the Sphinx
and the Pyramids.
And I find it
really fascinating,
because it has color coding.
It has images.
It has text.
It has a sense of continuity.
It has layers.
So things happen in
one country, but you
can start seeing also what
was happening in parallel
to Egypt-- so the tsunami
in Japan, bin Laden arrested
and killed, Occupy Wall Street,
and all these resonating events
between Tahrir and other
countries in the world.
And at the same time, being
quite a personal view of it,
because it's a
collection of elements
that I'm interested in because
of the nature of the work
I do and the type of material
I normally work with.
And so I actually focused
my archive on, again,
that production-- that
creative production
from the random
citizen and what I call
the popular language of Tahrir.
So these are early sketches of
my timeline made from a photo
that I took, videos
that I collected,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is a detail.
And then this is,
one of the graffitis
from Mohamed Mahmoud
Street that's is
one of the areas that come out
of Tahrir and where the street
graffiti artists of
the revolution have,
over and over and over
again, and overlaid
all these fantastic paintings
as things happened--
portraits of martyrs and so on.
And that huge, walled,
continuous street
is so extraordinary,
and constitutes a really
ongoing tableau vivant.
And that mix between that
kind of art in the street
and that influence of
that beautiful painting
and the social media
production that we experience
is, for me, sort of
missing something
that it needs to come together.
And so what I'm trying to
do is a kind of painting
of the 21st century, but that
is interactive so that you would
be immersed in as an
audience, but also
be able to kind of talk
to and look at in a way
that you would say,
OK, I'm interested.
And your question
is, what is the role
of the Army or the social
media in the revolution?
And so you would
only see-- suddenly,
the rest of the timeline
would sort of disappear.
And what comes forward
would be all the aspects
and all the moments in which
social media is actually
mentioned in an article,
or is in a hashtag of one
or another type of media
that is being displayed.
PROFESSOR: Well I
cannot wait to see it.
Seriously.
Is there questions specifically
on the presentation?
Because we're going to have a
discussion later on things that
you posted on the forum.
But is there any questions
related to what we spoke about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there
is kind of a place which
you said you built next to
real military base or something
like that?
How did they let you do that?
LARA BALADI: So
the military base
is a huge area that was
a little bit elitist.
So poor people were
not very welcomed.
And usually, they tended
to be kind of kicked out.
In the middle of it is the Opera
House, the Library of Music
and the Pavilion of Arts.
And all of this is
managed by the government,
the Ministry of Culture.
But the area and that whole
space belongs to the military.
And there's a military base
just next to the opera.
So it's surrounded by security.
It's very well guarded
and blah, blah, blah.
And one of the events
is, funny enough,
Egypt has one of the oldest
Bienniales of contemporary art.
So it's almost as
old as the Venice
Bienniale that's very famous.
And so for 25
years, there's been
every two years this event, this
art event, which is a disaster.
And it's like a horror show.
But that year,
December 2008, was
one of the iterations
of the Bienniale.
And for the first
time in 25 years,
they changed the curators
from the Minister of Culture
to two young men
that they appointed
to be taking care of that event.
And they asked me to be part of
the event, which was in itself
crazy, because I'm a woman.
I'm of Lebanese origin, so
I'm not a pure Egyptian.
I'm Christian.
I'm from the art world
that is more private, not
the government type artist,
so all of the things
that normally they hate.
And so it was, like,
wow, they're inviting me.
Of course I have to say yes.
But I also have to make a
point of my participation.
I don't want to just show
a collage or a piece that
is an interesting piece,
but not in this context.
So I want to actually respond
to where I'm going to show.
So I wanted to do
a work in situ.
And so I talked to the curator.
And I told him that's my idea.
I want to do this.
And I was very lucky, because
he said, oh, my god, I'm
really interested
in these areas.
And he, because he was
one of the first ones--
I mean, the first in 25 years
to have something really
radically happening and
changing in that structure
of the Bienniale, of course
he was happy to do something
provocative.
And he wanted to do
something provocative.
And he wanted his
Bienniale to be successful.
And already to choose
me was a problem.
So it was really funny.
So of course, he was
totally on my side.
And so I negotiated to
have a piece of land,
and to occupy this
little piece of land.
And then I had the
gardener come and tell me,
what are you doing
to my flowers?
And I don't know what.
I was, like, OK,
I'll do them again.
Just leave me work.
So it was very, very interesting
for all of these reasons,
because everybody
was waiting to see
what's going to happen, what
are they actually going to show?
Is it really going
to make a difference?
And it was a fascinating,
very exciting time.
And the work was
really very engaging,
because the people who built
the tower live in these areas.
And when they understood
what I was doing,
they became completely
in love with it.
And then the people who
guard that military base are
people who live in this area.
So they actually came
and did their naps.
They took naps inside my tower.
The people who owned
the cafes around,
the library and all of this
inside the garden surrounding
became familiar with me
building this for two months,
and then showing it
for another month.
And so every time
there was a visitor,
they would come
and offer coffee.
So it became a cafe.
I mean, it was incredible.
And I would come in the morning,
and find these huge ashtrays
full of cigarettes.
I was, like, who
smoked all this?
I would ask [INAUDIBLE]
who smoked all this?
He was, like, well, the
Director of the Opera House
came with his meeting, with
somebody he was meeting.
And they stayed three
hours, and smoked all night.
And so they were having
their meetings in that space.
So that space
became like a space.
It was super alive.
And it was really interesting,
because it helped, sort of.
People came to me
and said, you know,
normally, we see these areas are
as crime-ridden, ugly, horrible
people.
They have very
negative connotation.
And now I'm going to
go back to these areas
and look at it from
a different angle.
So it was this kind
of energy, and trying
to bring people to look at
themselves in a different way
and say, OK, wake up.
PROFESSOR: Well, I wish we
had more time to discuss.
It's so interesting,
all of this.
But we need to do
another presentation.
So I want to thank you.
Let's applaud Lara.
[APPLAUSE]
LARA BALADI: Thank you.